well that was a little weird affair last
night it was less of a debate and more
an awkward family squabble done in front
of all the neighbors I think if we're
gonna force Americans to make these
radical changes they're not going to go
along you throw your hands up but you
haven't
[Applause]
we're gonna come to you in one sec every
credible poll that I have seen has bee
beating Donald Trump Hillary Clinton was
winning in the polls to take who's
offering a false choice here you have
some so I think Democrats win when we
run on real solutions not impossible
promises when we run on things that are
workable not fairy tale economics I
don't understand why anybody does to all
the trouble of running for president of
the United States just to talk about
what we really can't do and shouldn't
fight for guys guys guys let's bring the
group counseling inside it's making the
kids and dogs uncomfortable thank God
there was a therapist on hand to make
things better or worse what do you say
to those Trump voters who prioritize the
economy over the president's bigotry no
bias there so what do you say to half
the country who are racist
no wonder CNN's bleeding viewers next
time leave the hard news to Jake and
bash but much of the debate came down to
three part episodes first a left-wing
candidate explains how to make
everything free second someone smarter
points out how you can't make everything
free third someone shouts but evil Trump
thank God Miss Cleo showed up if you
think any of this wonkiness is going to
deal with this dark psychic force of the
collectivized hatred that this president
is bringing up in this country then I'm
afraid that the Democrats are going to
see some very dark days hmm
love her or hate her she's got two
things in common with Trump she's no
politician and she's got a point of view
just don't ask her about her pet
died
that ain't no politician's answer but
she wasn't the only one with Trump on
the brain Donald Trump Donald Trump
Donald Trump Trump is a pathological
liar Donald Trump Donald Trump Donald
Trump that's how we're gonna beat Donald
Trump Donald Trump Donald Trump Donald
Trump disgraces the office of presidents
Donald Trump Donald Trump we've got to
get rid of Donald Trump Donald Trump
Donald Trump Donald Trump is the symptom
of a disease Donald Trump Donald Trump
let's get real tonight we debate but
ultimately we have to beat Donald Trump
now maybe it's me but all that talk
about Trump makes him even more alluring
it's like what dad says stay away from
those magazines at the barber shop you
think hey let's go check out those
magazines at the barber shop one laughed
at that it's weird how ten people
talking trash about you makes you seem
so much bigger
yep Trump loomed over the debate like
the devil in The Exorcist
reducing the party to a bunch of
possessed children helplessly shaking in
their beds no comfort came from that
room but also no candidate either Danna
I saw one of your perceptive tweets last
night and you you you do that thing with
you
I noticed not only was what was there
but what wasn't there and what wasn't
there what wasn't mentioned Dana well
first of all CNN I praise them for
starting a debate at 8:00 p.m. but what
wasn't there was the truth that it was
three hours long right two hours long I
don't know you said there was no mention
of impeachment and don't mauler
no collusion yeah and also no send her
back yes send her back with a victory
like and no Biden nope I denied nobody
mentioned any of those things that
obviously it's not going to be the case
tonight when Biden is on on the stage
the other thing that you mentioned that
Marianne has that Trump had she also has
a following yes a ready-made following
they've been following her for decades
it's not the same crowd that followed
president Trump through if you followed
him in New York or then when he was on
The Apprentice who became an
international star
Marianne is an international star as
well so I think she's couldn't founding
Democrats a little bit because like well
wait why does she have all this support
where's it coming from
she's been building it for years I also
like I do like the fact that I
understand what she's saying she's
waging a psychological battle wand and I
depth like he's talking about the psyche
of the nation and I think people can
understand that what do you what did you
make of deflect a family feud last night
between the moderates and the and the
not moderate first you know I listen to
your monologue with such interest and
then I heard about Miss Cleo myself
wasn't that she was the was she a black
woman on TV she was psychic
what's in she Miss Cleo the psychic the
1-800 number oh that was it you have to
dial 180s yes yes go now P dot 1-800 to
get married yes you get Marianne and but
I don't know she gets the way that's but
I must say she got lots of attention I
read and because this is so alien to me
I read she was the most searched person
on the stage last night in terms of
googling and the like right so I guess
people are like who is she
yes this about I think some of you know
who she is I really don't know yeah yes
because politically she's a nobody so
it's a little bit of a stunner I get the
whole Trump analogy that made it it's
like Trump yeah but you know what at
some point I think would she fall off
the stage for the next round apparently
not yeah I think she might have gone up
she has a following was there anybody
who liked the thing you thought he out
of the group that you thought was the
strongest well I think clearly Elizabeth
Warren came on the stage is the
strongest and left as a strong cuz I
don't think anybody did any damage to
yeah Warren to me the whole notion that
it's a family feud I think it's healthy
I think that's what we should be seeing
we should be seeing a debate yeah that
helps to determine who the carrot I mean
you look back to 2016
Republicans were far more divided really
and Ted little Marco low-energy
yeah you think about the wall there was
only one guy up there who said yeah
there was a great idea trade foreign
trade a not intervention or in Iraq
Donald Trump didn't tell the truth but
he said that he had opposed the war in
Iraq or something I did yeah
directionally told the truth you know
but I thought that was a real
substantive debate about Medicare for
all about the environment with Delaney
playing the foil to Sanders and warrant
making some real good points in forcing
them to defend their points and then
when he spoke about the cost that we're
gonna do that in to be block okay let's
do it in the d-block all right Jesse you
call it a squabble you called it a
I said it was an intervention this was
the rise of the realists who are trying
to rescue the party away from socialism
and the Bernie and Warren they're just
lighting themselves on fire right now
this is a big bonfire of socialism and
all these realists are like throwing
water on and like hey map reality okay
this is going to get us killed in a
landslide but they don't care they just
want to light everything on fire so the
audience and the audience claps every
time some socialist says something crazy
you know what's popular it is socialism
is popular social about that
you know silver Colts too and the 70s
won I'm not saying it's gonna work
something's popular doesn't mean it's
going to be good right now I think
what's happening is Warren I disagree I
thought she was frenetic I thought she
was annoying she failed the
commander-in-chief test when she took
the first nuke strike option a table
like she's gonna sacrifice an American
city and let North Korea throw a missile
over here and then then respond after
we've lost millions of people absolutely
crazy she refused to answer the question
about whether she'd raise taxes on the
middle class and then Bernie gets out
there Bernie's got nothing in Washington
his whole career he only knows how to
take he doesn't know how to create and
he just a rageaholic
no one was presidential timber no one
had any sense of humor Marianne
Williamson
she's like homeopathic therapy just like
an aspirin bear and she's like yoga like
CVD oil and she's but she's tapped into
some energy in the country I just don't
think that energy is fully formed yet
but she's got into it what about you
Emily what did you wear were your
highlights and lowlights yeah I think
it's interesting I agree with part of
what you said to me it was like a Hunger
Games style big fish in a small pond and
the progressives won to me I think
Bernie emerged as the commander and that
he and Elizabeth were clearly the pros
on stage but they failed at that
commander level I agree I think to me it
was clear that the progressives won but
at what cost to the party at what cost
to the reality of the moderate faction
which to me was eclipsed I think that
the aha moments and the dramatic moments
the zingers and the quips got all the
applause and got all the excitement but
in reality I think a lot of voters at
home were like well I would like
actually more info from that moderate
over there and I would like more airtime
from that moderate over there and so to
me it was analogy of once again
CNN taking away the choice from the
voter at home really dead were you
couldn't really get full answers because
the rules that they had set out had the
moderators were forced then to try to
cut off everybody just as they were
about to make a point right cut them off
yeah I thought I thought two-thirds of
the moderators did a really good job I
thought that I thought that they must
have been cringing with lemon going just
editorializing I thought was a bit odd I
mean it's like having me up there yeah I
mean you know he's in self-defense mode
but you know to me there were two
outstanding moments one for the
Democrats one when Elizabeth Warren says
to the so-called moderates I think
they're more conservative hey if why are
you running for president just to tell
us what we can't do
Fran the other one was Pete Muir Pete
saying oh you know what the Republic is
going to call a socialist whether you
are liberal or conservative social now
but the ground has shifted under their
feet yes because a party has moved so
far left then you're ended up you end up
being called a conservative Democrats
exactly for the most tweeted about
candidate was though by the way it was
still Trump yeah so no matter what
happened it was still trouble